hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
hail pan show joining me today we have
the founder of mice media we're going to
be discussing everything from web3 and
how it's revolutionizing the internet to
censorship building online Brands and
online communities Brynn Davis welcome
to the show how are you I'm doing really
well how are you I'm doing really well
thank you it's so good to have you here
I know you have had a hectic February
yes so before we talk about censorship
and mice media and everything that um is
going on in web three what has been
going on with you in February because I
know it's been crazy February has been
nuts it's really where we started that
beginning of our mint and now we're
executing at the end of the month and
we've been jam-packed so it started off
with we were the first web3 Network to
cover the Super Bowl which was which was
really exciting we had a ton of exposure
and got to meet some great people there
I got back to Philadelphia quickly hop
down here to meet with you as well as
speak with some investors and then um
tonight I leave for Paris we're speaking
at nft Paris and uh covering that event
as well and after that I shoot right
over to Tbilisi Georgia to work with our
development team to really execute and
bring this network to fruition so when
you told me that you're the first web3
platform covering the Super Bowl I
thought that's just incredible that's
that's insane that's mainstream adoption
but not a lot of people have heard of
the time web 3 or they've heard about
and they don't really know what it is so
before we get into everything can you
explain what is web3
um in comparison to what is web one and
what is web 2. so let's start with web
one and how you know web to web 2 and
web 3 is an evolution of that so I think
when it comes to what we're building the
best the best references you know web
one was very much that read-only era of
the internet right where you were you
were reading a website and that was
pretty much it it was a place to post
information you look at web 2 I think
web 2 was really dominated by social
media networks right that peer-to-peer
uh experience online which was great uh
but I think what happened is on those
social media platforms
um you know it was supposed to be that
that Town Square it was supposed to be
where you could express yourself freely
Etc and I think quickly we learned that
you know that wasn't the case right
whether it be censorship or D platform
Etc you were allowed to say whatever you
want so long as you said what you were
supposed to say
um so now that we move into web three
and for me I like to Define that error
more more than even using the word
blockchain or nfts or cryptocurrency is
decentralization in general right I
think that's the massive weapon that
that web3 promises and uh you know in a
lot of Industries I think the central
centralization is the cure specifically
when it comes to you know I think the
first the first example of that would be
with cryptocurrency right you had
central banks that obviously had too
much control uh you had you know Finance
financial institutions that also had too
much control so it was ripe for
disruption through decentralization you
see that through cryptocurrency I think
if you look at the next industry that
has the same exact set of issues or
symptoms it's media right the power of
the narrative is in the hands of the few
and therefore we have massive distrust
for the internet so uh or for the media
so to me decentralization when applied
to an industry like media I think isn't
just a fun way or a new way of looking
at it but I actually think that it
solves the problem that the media
industry is facing right now yeah it's a
huge issue and it's one that I face all
the time on this channel so we'll pick
our words carefully we don't want to
trigger any algorithms but um you know I
had a video taken down talking about
um the Jib Jab as we like to call it um
talking about lots of different things
that we're not allowed to talk about
um crazy especially because you know
what is regarded as
um misinformation is constantly changing
so you know one week what I said isn't
true but the next week what I said is
true so you know I think we desperately
need um some kind of web through
alternative so what is mice media how
are you providing this alternative well
I think you know you're talking about
putting up a video it's deemed as
misinformation and then not a lot of
that decision-making process is coming
from that Corporation right they're
deciding what can and can't go on and
usually the people that make the
decision whether there's a publicly
traded company or private is a small
group right and they're really
protecting themselves they're not really
worried about what information is going
out they just don't want have to have
any Scandal or anything along those
lines I think that with decentralization
the way that we're building a media
network is there is no boardroom there
is no investor there is no Corporation
over top of us and the community is the
investor rather than being the consumer
so in that case we don't have the same
pressure whether it be politically or
from a network or from investors to
censor what's being said right I think a
lot of times you know what we say is
because we've had some very polarizing
figures come on our Network pre-network
meaning on our Twitter space and stuff
like that that again are polarizing uh
but you know we what our team always
says is you know we don't have to agree
with what they say but we absolutely
agree with their right to say it and a
lot of times what we found is when
people say provocative things I'll use
Tommy Robinson I'm not sure if you know
Tommy yeah as a British person every
Britain is coming yeah so so Tom I mean
Tommy's when it comes to a case study
for our media network is perfect right
Tommy has a pretty hard line approach
when it comes to to Islam and and to the
effect that it had on Luton and when we
announced that he was coming on you know
there was a huge backlash of like oh my
gosh how are you having this guy on et
cetera et cetera and you know the thing
with someone like Tommy is this he says
something right and the the media will
take a piece of what he says kind of put
it out there
it'll it'll create a big Ripple and then
they take away his stage and cancel him
right so he has no ability to speak and
encounter what anybody's saying about
him which is which is a travesty
um so when we have Tommy on you know
what we told our told our listeners was
at the end of this conversation you
still might not agree with Tommy
whatsoever right you might have nothing
in common with him but that context as
to how he got to that opinion that's
where the juice is right is figuring out
how he got there I think a lot of times
you look at the 90s and early 2000s the
media interaction whether it's on CNN or
Fox News it's it's taking that thing
that was said yelling back and forth and
that was entertainment I think now we've
been kind of desensitized to that model
and having a curious conversation as to
why he thinks the way he thinks and
giving him that stage and not ripping it
away is I think you know Paramount yeah
it's so interesting because I think that
is the sign of an intelligent individual
if you're willing to sit there and
listen and understand how somebody
landed there
that's the best that's the best thing
you can do I think more people should do
that instead of you know screaming
Grandma killer or you're ruining
people's lives or you know you're you're
a Nazi and all these stupid things you
know it's people should say hang on like
why are you you know concerned about x y
and Zed absolutely absolutely yeah in
that I think the juice is in the context
right 99 of the time and you know
following again using them following
that our night with him the response was
wild uh and and it really you know I
think solidified and made me feel good
about the path that we're going because
again not everybody agreed with him by
the end but it was interesting I think
they were informed they learned
something they don't have to agree with
them but I think I think they learned
and uh you know when you get that
narrative and story as to how he got
there things tend to make a little bit
more sense it's funny because I think
Tommy Robinson has been um now
de-platform from Twitter so I think you
had him before I don't think he's on
Twitter anymore under Elon musk's regime
he's not on there anymore what's crazy
about about Tommy who I who who I'll see
in France week is so when I met him he
was not on Twitter then he was
reinstated right and he immediately I
mean overnight had 50 000 followers his
people call it talk about a community in
in web 2 or community on social media
his community is the most supportive
Community I've ever seen when he does
something
I think I think is that some competition
to Andrew yeah Andrew's Andrew has the
same thing right but uh
since he has been de-platformed again
from Twitter so he's off and on he has a
love-hate relationship with Twitter I
think yeah yeah and it's funny because
actually de-platforming somebody in my
opinion makes them a hero like it makes
them a martyr and then it makes people
curious as to why this person was
de-platformed people then end up
searching for them joining their
newsletters and then becoming more
involved in that person's
um narrative and opinion so really it's
almost counterproductive don't you think
totally agree it's almost like a
business model to get de-platformed a
lot of times will help you out right
because now all of a sudden you're in
the news again or you're on top of mind
and people want to know why you got the
platform so it's an interesting uh
situation yeah so in terms of
decentralization uh can you talk to me a
little bit about about why it's so
important and what it actually means for
Content Creation in the future yeah so
so we look at it two different ways
right the way the way that I I initially
so when I when I uh had my first I guess
introduction into web3 right the first
article that I read about web3 what I
thought was breathtaking about the model
model was that the ownership can be
democratized right I spent a lot of
times work a lot of time working in
venture capital and it's a nightmare
because you're pitching the brand to a
few people it's just it's like an
outdated system when I saw
decentralization in terms of how to
build a brand I thought it was
breathtaking you were able to activate a
community that would usually be your
fans but now they're actually instead of
it being a brand and the supporters
you're all together now because they're
a part of what you're building so the
fundamental uh structure as to how mice
media is built is decentralized so then
you talk about the network itself right
so how is the network decentralized
so with our with mice media what we've
done is embedded in our Network are all
the tools for any individual to be able
to create content right so you know you
talk about the different uh genres in
the news right you look at that old
newspaper it used to be you know uh news
and politics Sports text business
whatever right
um
in each of those portals we give the
ability for the individual to create
content right someone like you who would
be on a much higher level or an
individual who wants to have a podcast
we decentralized that so individuals can
create the content and put it on the
network right so there's not that
barrier between Network and and consumer
um and you know that that that
democratization and you know leaning
into that whole you know citizen
journalism side of things is the way
that we curate that content but I think
the biggest distinction is you know
especially if you're talking about web 3
and utility let's say right it's not as
though that network is only going to be
contributed to by mice holders right
we're an outward facing media Network
that's built by the mice holders so for
us there's a hierarchy in terms of how
that decentralized content actually
works right so number one is you know
there is anybody who is able to make
content or willing to make content can
but at the same time we're able to
aggregate content from other media
outlets and put it on our platform we
also have contributors that work for
mice that really anchor down all of
those different genres and then we end
up being able to democratize it so
anybody can contribute so it's really
just a free-form uh you know like you
said decentralized or democratized
approach to media content
it's just so fascinating because it's so
um in contrast to what we have now where
we have these major
um you know tech companies who have a
huge Monopoly on the market so can you
explain to us how companies like Google
and Facebook
um control web 2 and then also control
the information I think with web 2
especially talk about Facebook I don't
think we knew what we were signing up
for everything was so new when we
started signing up for social media
right when you went on that platform you
didn't realize what you were actually
giving up so I think they were able to
get a massive amount of market share
just because the technology was new and
nobody really understood it I think you
know when you talk about creators and
you talk about content and you talk
about someone like YouTube let's say or
or any of those Outlets is because they
got so much market share so fast they
were able to be piggish in terms of the
the revenue that they receive for people
that put out great content right so
someone puts out a YouTube video that
gets a million hits YouTube's gonna tip
from that ad spend YouTube's gonna take
what 90 of it maybe more right the only
reason they can do that is because
they're the biggest show in town and
they were there first and they have the
market so for us right I think you know
the the opportunity and the
responsibility even is to flip the
script right so when somebody creates
content on our Network number one
we're going to not take 90 we're going
to be the ones maybe taking 10 or less
so that's number one right but that's
such a a a linear approach to monetizing
content is just through ad spend there's
so many different ways to reward the
Creator for putting out valuable content
and that's what we've done so number one
is you know let's say that you're you're
going to have a live stream or you're
going to have a show right on our
platform you could make that a ticketed
event so that somebody pays a dollar two
dollars five dollars to watch that
individual stream right if somebody
watches it and wants to tip you they're
able to tip you in real time right
through the platform uh you can have the
same thing in terms of subscribers but
not only do we take less of that
percentage from like a nine to one ratio
but on top of that we layer in all these
different other opportunities for
monetization so you see these people on
Twitter spaces right now in the web 3
world that'll get 10 20 30 000 listeners
now for a two hour show and they're not
making anything the hope is that we'll
get some followers and we'll figure out
how to monetize them later and then it
so for us if those same Outlets if we
made it frictionless which we'd have to
click and pay a dollar that individual
if half the people do it that's a twenty
thousand dollar you know uh Twitter
space that now all of a sudden it can
really build a brand and the network or
the platform is not taking that money I
think that you know we have a huge
opportunity to reward the creators that
are really what's making this whole
industry spin yeah as a Creator I think
that's hugely valuable and also it
provides a really important incentive to
bring people over to these platforms
because you know we're having these
conversations about how bad YouTube is
and yet this is going out on YouTube so
we we are almost our own worst enemies
because we continue to financially
support the companies that we don't like
so
um no this this is good I think it
provides an incentive for us to actually
migrate well the irony is crazy right so
if you look at the nft world right
everybody's out there preaching
decentralization right that's that's
what we stand for or whatever and we're
preaching that on a very very
centralized platform exactly which is
which is wild right yeah so I think you
know and what we've looked at with our
team is when it comes to web three right
that umbrella with nfts cryptocurrency
et cetera very infrequently are tools
made for web3 specifically for web 3. we
find tools like Twitter spaces or
whatever or Discord that were made for
other things and we apply it to web3 so
our Paradigm was let's create it for
this industry right that section of our
media Network that's for technology
let's create it for people in web 3 and
I think by doing so you're able to you
know account for taking care of creators
uh you know pushing valuable content and
so forth one of the things that I talk
about on this podcast is how I believe
that
um big Tech is in bed with governments
and we saw that anyway
um on Twitter when the Twitter files
came out and how
um you know they were instructing
Twitter to take down certain posts and
it was all very political we saw the
same thing with Facebook
um so have you seen this and also why do
you think this is so yeah I mean I think
it was crazy because originally my at
first blush my knee-jerk reaction was
hey if it's Twitter or it's Facebook
whatever it is it is their brand right I
mean although we want it to be a Public
Square it doesn't have to be they can do
whatever they want right see wait I push
back on that a little bit yeah the only
reason I push back originally I would
agree with you private companies do what
they want however and again you can tell
me if I think we're gonna end up in the
same spot but go ahead okay so then you
go okay fine so I was just gonna say it
was Elon Musk that did a tweet that
basically said Twitter has now evolved
into the This Town Square at the time
that you used and so now I do believe
that um Twitter has a responsibility to
the public to provide a public sphere
where for free information and where
people have the opportunity to learn and
have access to all sorts of information
diverse
um content and diverse information just
because of how big it's grown I do
believe that it does have that
responsibility despite it being a public
company totally agree I think it has the
responsibility too especially if someone
like one says that right he says that
you have to follow it through but I
think you know theoretically put that
aside you know if I'm looking at it as a
free from a free market perspective the
the individual Network can do whatever
they want right but the second that the
government gets involved with that
process everything's out the window once
the government's uh forcing it like like
you saw with the Twitter files is uh
then it becomes this kind of collusive
scenario where it looks like the
government's controlling the social
media Outlets Etc which is you know
again while I think decentralization is
so important not on the content side but
in the creation side of the actual
entity because you know the reason that
those that those Outlets you would are
biased or are politically influenced is
because there's a small group of people
that can be influenced to create that
kind of uh culture for their Network
when you don't have those few people and
rather you have thousands of people that
are the governance and ownership of the
network you're not going to have that
same pressure you're not going to be as
effective of influencing a network when
it's owned by that many people so I
think that's one of the reasons why uh
decentralized media is massively
disruptive
so talk to me about mice media again
because we touched on this but I want to
get more detail about your community and
how you're actually able to
um enable free speech and I'm going to
take a quote from your website
um it says
you are the first political nft to hit
blockchain tackling free speech and
censorship to disrupt woke media I love
that you put woke me doing that that's
funny
um so what's special about your
community what are you doing how are you
disrupting woke media no I love that
that was one of the outlets that covered
us and that quote I think was perfect
especially for a sector of our followers
that that that epitomizes really well
right so it kind of comes back to the
first time that I even really saw what
web3 was right so I'm I'm 38 when I was
22 I started my first brand right okay
uh and it was a 15-year run we started
off in Philadelphia we ended up having
locations everywhere from the
Philadelphia area over into East Africa
and and they were they were healthy fast
food restaurants and uh at the end of
that right you talk about a year and a
half ago or so
um the pandemic came through and it
either mandated the closure of a lot of
our restaurants or it made it so that
people couldn't come in and eat Etc and
it just made what I had built for 15
years not
what we started off with right it really
you know became a tough situation due to
all those mandates so I was in one of
the final restaurants that we had and I
get this art I read this article in
Rolling Stone about poor Davis I had no
idea what what web3 was never heard the
word nft and you know as I was reading
it you know my mind was blown that a
project can put art out right and then a
community manifests around that and
there's value my mind was blown this is
breathtaking but because I was on the
outside I looked at it as well that's
great right to to create a community
around art but what if you tapped into
an existing Community or culture and
then gave it a space on web3 kind of
kind of flipped the script there right
understood yeah so you know at this time
as everybody knows and that during the
pandemic everybody was consuming media
they're either watching TV or they're on
social media because they can't leave
their house and at that point in time I
think media probably had the worst
reputation it has in the last 20 30
years right
um you know whether it's it's mass media
everything that you're getting is biased
and skewed and highly opinionated and
all social media like we said before
cancel cultures at its height people are
getting to platforms so you know as we
were building that initial Community it
was people that were tired of that media
control right so what I think is unique
about our community is that it's not
because we have a shared interest in a
JPEG or art It's really because we
tapped into a culture that already
exists and I the reason that I think our
the Project's done as well as it has so
far is because you know
first thing is you know you you
establish yourself on web3 you create
your community and then there's that
whole component of utility I think a lot
of brands are looking to check off that
box they need to say they have some
utility right so they're going to say oh
we're going to create a video game in
the future or oh we're going to do
something you know whatever uh to me
what's what's very novel about what
we've built is the community came
together because of a problem right and
the utility solves that problem creating
a network that is the answer an
antithesis of the networks that that we
didn't like really creates a cohesive
narrative and I think that's why uh to
this point we've had such a Vibrant
Community and had the attraction that
we've had well it's so interesting
because nfts have evolved so much they
used to be just all jpegs and for me
personally I was unable to see the value
in it other than you know authenticating
something on the blockchain
um but talk to me about how it's evolved
in terms of actually providing utility
whether it's you know a a ticket to
access a live stream whether it's a
ticket to have you know access and a
gateway to a community like how has it
evolved and then especially in terms of
mice media like what are you offering
um in terms of utility yeah no I
completely agree it boggles my mind uh
when when you look at these amazing
projects out there and what they're
doing with these powerful tools that we
have right the blockchain smart
contracts decentralization those are
those are some massive tools that we can
put to use and we're putting them into
use in my opinion like you're saying for
art and silly things where it's fine but
there's so much more out there right so
to me uh you know an nft project the art
is something that is just at this point
I think something that you need to offer
so that people can use it and feel like
there's something there but the value
comes in the utility more than anything
else so in our case for the utility of
Of Mice media you know we we did go
through and apply a lot of that
traditional media that you find in Nat
projects so people have the IP rights
right uh worry we we've already had
before men we had an in real life event
out in Arizona we're also going to have
one out in Paris so there's value there
as well we do the in real life and
digital merchandise all these things
that all these projects do that do have
value we do and that's great but for us
the massive value is in fundamentally
creating an outward facing brand mice
media Network which is for the whole
entire Market but it's built by our
holders so they participate in that
growth and then in that governance but
in terms of what they can actually do
within that Network
as that Network proliferates and grows
just like any other network from Daily
Beast to daily wire or any of these
large ones you have right most of them
are on a subscription-based Model the
first and easy one is that all of our
holders have access to all of that
content and perpetuity forever right uh
Additionally you know I think when you
look at when you when you when a lot of
people would say okay so it's
decentralized media they Embrace free
speech so this is going to be a media
Network like a CNN or Fox News but
really just lean into the into the Free
Speech part right I think that's pretty
bland if you look at other media
networks right now right whether it's
again Fox News MSNBC CNN it's almost
like they all use the same templated Wix
site and just inserted different
opinions it's a read-only or watch only
there's nothing else you either read a
story or you watch a story that's it so
if you were truly to you know completely
drop all preconceived notions about what
media should be right and completely
reinvent it what would it be right now
how would we want to interact with media
how would we want to consume media so
for us you know we look back at how this
all started right you know when I was
growing up and probably for 150 years
before that people woke up in the
morning they got their newspaper and a
cup of coffee and within an hour they
were informed right and when you looked
at that front page of the news
you're able to see all the highlights of
what's going on and then turn to the
page that you actually want to read more
about right and you know as technology
progresses there's Real Time news now
the newspaper doesn't really make sense
because it's outdated by the time you
read it it's old news all that stuff
right so for us there was there was
still a gap in that experience of going
to one place seeing a snapshot of what's
going on and then being able to dive
further into what you're interested in
so what we've constructed is a dashboard
right a media dashboard that does the
same thing that that newspaper used to
do it has the five genres of uh you know
news and politics Sports Tech business
and lifestyle right same thing but when
you look at that dashboard it does show
you the highlights of what's going on in
each of those areas right and then as
you click and go into that portal then
the world opens up entirely so you know
when you get into that portal yeah
there's the read new read-only news and
there's the there's the video news but
let's talk about you know uh news and
politics for example
um you know once you enter that part of
our site is there a debate a live debate
that's going on through a Tommy Robinson
and Andrew Tate is there um you know is
there someone that's uh that has did a
video cast and live stream that you can
watch in real time right and a lot of
those events are going to be ticketed or
a lot of those events are going to be
you know there's going to be a barrier
to entry for for the average subscriber
the average viewer but for our for our
holders they have free access to every
single thing that goes on in that
Network we're pretty heavy on the sports
side as well we have a lot of former
athletes a lot of Hall of Fame athletes
that are contributors to our Network
right so as they hold those events on
our platform uh where it's for a small
amount of people and it's a hundred
dollars to enter that event our holders
have full access to do anything in that
ecosystem
how are you different and and also just
what's your take on the broader nft
space
um you know the infamous body Yacht Club
you know the the crypto punks like what
is your take on them first of all I'm a
huge fan of board Apes because that was
my introduction into this space right so
it always holds a you know a place in my
heart and I give those I think right now
there's so much more you can do in web 3
than what board Apes did but that's not
their fault necessarily right because as
the first movers you know I give them
all the credit in the world they Blaze
the trail for everybody else to go down
so everybody that builds right now is
kind of on the shoulders of the brands
that did it first yeah so
um you know when I say that there's a
lot more to do I still think that they
did a tremendous job but you know I talk
about the kind of the evolution of
really any Trend or any industry right
it always starts off with the artists
right the artists and the creators then
it moves into the entrepreneurs the
people who see it and see okay this is
this is a cool business model and then
it kind of goes into that corporate
sphere where they know that there's
money there and then it's not as fun and
vibrant of an industry as it was before
and I think right now we're still in
between that artist and entrepreneur
stage so you know to me the the power of
the smart contract and the ability to
build a brand using the blockchain is
the most fascinating part of this right
um and I think that we're going to find
a lot more brands that intentionally
build with the community
um as you know holder or as owners of
that actual brand I'll tell you what
what blew my mind because when I looked
at it initially uh I had a different I
had a different
Viewpoint so when I read that first
article about board Apes right and I'm
reading that there's ten thousand Apes
the community is vibrant they're pushing
the brand I'm thinking this is amazing
I'd spend a lot of time raising money
for the my previous company I'm thinking
this is an amazing way to raise Capital
right people buy into this project
they're able to have equity in that
project and it proliferates and it grows
and that's not the case when you buy a
board ape you own a of your board ape
and zero percent of Yuga
so to me that's kind of odd right and I
think a lot of purists would say that's
the way it should be this is the way
that the industry should be built Etc
but you know it's inevitable to me that
somebody's going to be able to figure
out hopefully yes somebody's going to be
able to figure out how to apply a
security to an nft how can Equity be
built into that smart contract because
I think especially in our case or a
brand like ours is when you buy that nft
if it offer also represented a piece of
that brand that's magical right because
then you look at the value of the nft
and it's really split there there
there's the traditional Rarity scarcity
and you know the hype that's around the
project that drives it but if it's
reflective of a share of that company
then right then and there it has x
amount as value and when you fuse those
two together that that's pretty amazing
and I think inevitably that's going to
happen and you know when you know it's
the mom test when when it was what we
call it right in explaining what an nft
is it's still difficult you have to go
through all these you have to jump
through all these hoops if you said an
nft is the digital representation of
ownership in a brand immediately it's
understood you buy a piece of the brand
and that and that's how that that's how
you participate in having shares I think
that inevitably that's where the puck is
going yeah and whoever can get there
first I think is is going to break some
massive barriers yeah no I agree with
you I mean especially in terms of
regular like regulation I think
Regulators aren't going to miss an
opportunity to consider many different
things Securities and shares in
companies because right now I know I
know there is that gray area
um with regards to nfts but if you if
you fractionalize something and you turn
them into you know digital ownership
those are securities but if you don't
fractionalize it then there's just an
nft so I agree with you we're going
there it's going to become extremely
mainstream
um and I mean Regulators aren't going to
miss an opportunity to to get involved
in that no and and I think that's just
breaks larger than I think it'd be a
great model for our brand it breaks
Venture Capital as a whole think about
it right right now in order to invest in
a brand that's not public you have to be
in credit investors to go through the
SEC you have to do all these goddamn
things and it makes it so that there's a
huge barrier to entry so only a few
people can play once somebody's able to
break that model and apply a security to
a Smart contract think about how amazing
it would be to see a startup right be
able to buy an nft and participate in
the ownership of that right and even
better like the stock market you have
liquidation whenever you want you're
able to sell one of your entities half
of it whatever in real time and I think
that it just creates an incredibly
robust private sector non-public
business uh you know ecosystem that you
know when it happens I think is going to
turn the Venture Capital World in its
head yeah again I'm still interested to
see how Regulators are gonna how they're
gonna uh deal with all of this it's
gonna be fascinating just because
there's gonna be some Wars oh yeah you
know just because you know you've got to
be an accredited investor and you have
to be this level and that level and yeah
it's going to be fascinating to see how
it plays out there is going to be Wars
and the wars are already starting um but
speaking of Wars um I think Andrew Tate
is somebody who kind of like epitomizes
everything we've we've sort of discussed
in terms of um you know censorship free
speech trying to understand how somebody
landed with an opinion rather than you
know being upset about their opinion
um and obviously he's uh being
de-platformed he's also now in jail
which is pretty crazy I think actually
yesterday they uh they announced that
they're going to be extending that but
you have this weird ironic story
um with Andrew which is interesting so
can you can you just tell me about it
and how you how you know him yes so once
we started getting into like this this
circle of free speech and censorship
it's a wild group right it's a pretty
small group and it's pretty connected
that's true yeah it's big but everybody
knows everything everybody knows
everybody it's very specific yeah it's
bizarre and I I step foot into that
maybe you know six months ago and I was
introduced to Tommy Robinson who I told
you about right and uh Tommy uh you know
if you look them up online you'd think
that he's a Nazi crazy individual if you
ever speak to Tommy he's a heart of gold
and he's a nice guy even if you don't
agree with what he says right so we're
talking to Tommy and I'm explaining
we're building with mice media he had no
really idea about the blockchain
anything like that didn't have a digital
wallet but was hooked like really hooked
we talked every day for a long time and
we'll meet him this weekend and I'm
telling him I'm talking about this
project and talking about what we're
building and he goes uh hold on I have a
friend who would be very very interested
give me one second let me call him and
see if you and see if he'll talk to you
and I was like okay I had no idea I'm
thinking that's like his buddy I have no
idea who he's talking about so I was
like cool I said he gets back on the
phone and says hey my buddy's he's my
mate my mate's ready to talk my mates
it doesn't come out doesn't flow from my
mouth correctly he said can you hop on
the phone I said sure I got on it's
Andrew Tate now this is the month after
he had been like the most Google band in
the world or whatever and uh so we
talked to Andrew
incredibly nice human his his I think
his cousin Luke was the one that we
dealt with as well incredibly nice guy
and what ended up happening was you know
I didn't want our brand to be epitomized
by one person if Andrew wanted to get in
an nnt project it would sell out in five
minutes and that's great but that would
be an Andrew project correct so Andrew
uh is a holder of roughly 10 10 mice
right right which is which is fun
um and it was crazy because uh we had a
Twitter space we hold some monster
Twitter spaces and I'd ask them to come
on I think I said can you come on
tomorrow the next day he said yes and
literally that was the day that he was
he was taken away the next day oh wow
and it's baffling but you know the first
question I got from our community was
would you still have Andrew on now that
this news came out and I said of course
yeah because it's the same thing of
again you know Andrew could speak the
worst part of it is when it comes to
media in that case is when a story about
Andrew comes out it's an opinion about
Andrew that comes out right the first
thing you're going to hear is the
opinion and then they'll maybe sprinkle
in some loose facts but it's the opinion
there's nothing better than getting
information directly from the source it
doesn't mean that it's correct it
doesn't mean you have to agree with it
but I'd love to have Andrew explain his
part of the story and where it came from
doesn't mean I support it so you know I
think that's that's the way that our
Network operates and hopefully when he
when he gets out which I thought it was
soon but when he gets out uh hopefully
we'll be able to get him on yeah I don't
know when he's getting out everyone
keeps asking me and I don't know I know
that the women have been
um put on house arrests so that's like
you know one stage towards a little bit
of normality but I don't know
um well what what is your take
um on Andrew being canceled and other
you know people being canceled like
Tommy Robinson and Alex Jones and um
yeah there's many people Kanye West like
what's your take on that
I mean again if you take out that that
government element right that happened
around the last election uh then I think
you know what it'll the platform can do
whatever it wants which I think is a
huge opportunity because then if you
create a platform that doesn't have that
same level of censorship the market I
believe will gravitate towards that
ecosystem or that media Network and
that's where where we exist right so if
Twitter or Facebook or whoever doesn't
want to allow those individuals on you
know because they don't agree with what
they say they think that you know it's
hurtful or whatever whatever their
opinion is fine that's great let them do
whatever they want but let's create a
home for those individuals on both sides
of the aisle that they don't have to
worry about being censored being
de-platformed and all of those different
things I mean a lot of these guys those
some the people that you named are
obviously very high profile but if you
look at other people who create content
on let's say YouTube right that's their
livelihood yeah that's right they have
to wake up I talk to other people like
this all the time they wake up in the
morning and check their YouTube account
first just to make sure they're still on
that's not fair right unless you're
inciting like violence or something
insane which I'll pretend you are by the
way yeah yeah
don't get the Jib Jab you're inciting
violence but anyway we had we had a guy
that was a part of our Network early on
young kid 17 crazy he had he was coming
up on a half a billion views on YouTube
he was a man in the street and he'd go
up and ask Trump or Biden right that's
so funny yep that was it that was the
question it was actually kind of Genius
because you got these amazing responses
such a simple question and again he's on
his way to a half a billion hits in in
two or three months it was crazy and not
only did they never allow him to
monetize they never they never did that
but on top of that that once it came to
the point where he'd applied for it and
gone through they they took him off they
gave him a forever band no warnings they
were happy to collect the ad money that
they that they obviously earned that
they earned through his content but no
warnings no strikes no two strikes oh my
God me and my brother need to have a
conversation after this we need to
brilliant young man we need to be
careful wow
when it comes to creators like him or
someone that usually creates on YouTube
and our Network is you know what we say
to them is continue to create on YouTube
if that's where your Market is do it if
if your Market's on any of these other
outlets stay there rock it but also even
if it's as an insurance policy by
putting that content on our media
Network you know that you're at least
not going to be the platform there and I
think a lot of times with traditional
corporate networks if you're working
with them or for them you cannot do
anything else they own everything that
you do I think that that is an outdated
model and for the people that create
content for us and with us create it
everywhere you would like but also have
a home with us and I think between that
and not taking the Lion's Share of
profits from people that create you
become a very approachable and open
network which is just so different than
the networks that we're dealing with
right now so how do people get involved
like how do I stop working on mice media
how do I put my content on mice media
how does it work okay so in terms of the
networking it being delivered again two
things number one is I leave for Georgia
will be there about 30 to 60 and we our
Tech stack is already built so all the
features that I've already told you
about are there what we're doing now is
connecting that digital dashboard into
our Tech stack so that it's an outward
facing brand and again we'll talk about
like 30 60 days that'll be out there in
Georgia
um so that's when the network will be
available uh for people to create so
quickly I mean a lot of times with
entity projects the roadmap is this in
the future hopefully it'll happen or
whatever for us it's already done and
you know a lot of people look at uh you
know mints like an nft mint as like a
crowd crowd funding and I hate that
right uh for me that the value of the
community the value of having a
community is so much more valuable than
the money that you get from that Mint or
community so it was important for us to
curate the best possible community and
culture to contribute to that Network
and I mean if we wanted let's say you
know from a mint you get a couple
million dollars I'd say right it would
be
drastically easier for us to go out and
raise that amount of money by going the
traditional Venture Capital route
getting a couple people to give a bunch
of money yeah so by first having that
Community uh
we're in as as the the media networks is
a reflection of that Community built by
the community I want to give two or
three months to really feel out our
community and see what's valuable to
them and see what they want while we
build the network and then again we're
talking about maybe two three months
from now we'll go full throttle and open
up that Network entirely sounds amazing
it's so exciting
um you know I think now is the time we
desperately need it and I think as well
um more and more people are waking up to
the reality that censorship is real it's
happening and governments are working
with big Tech in order to push different
agendas push uh you know election
results or whatever it is so
um not Now's the Time so it's super
exciting amen yeah well um Brent I want
to thank you so much it's been such a
pleasure having you on thank you so much
for having me I really appreciate it
thanks so much for watching if you
enjoyed this content then don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe as
we're going to be bringing you a lot
more we'll see you all next week